when we were there like ali remembers um
it was it was a vibe i almost feel like
and i know this might sound uh
sacrilegious but i almost feel like the
angels were there with me on that day i
do feel like there was something going
on in that day that something happened
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
today we're joined with a very special
guest i think this episode we've all
been waiting for for a long time we have
with us
how are you doing
not bad
not bad at all how are you guys doing
so um we don't have too long so we're
going to start this off with the banging
shot logan do a quick fire q a
yeah let's make it happen
some negative externalities some noise
pollution some problems some extraneous
variables some issues
uh it's the one and only uh
champ and uh
and his friend
but uh sorry if there's any if there's
any like noise in the background there's
nothing i can do about that
i'm a little stranger
all right let's get on with this is
money more
depends on what the objective is really
i mean we've got to think about what the
objective is
everything must be thought of in line
with uh one's objectives so what what
are the objectives that you have in mind
um i meant that
for me personally yeah well you know to
be honest with you like maybe about five
or six years ago
i've never ever made diet for money in
my life i don't think i've ever made
diet for it uh i've never asked allah
for money
i don't i that might be a come to as a
surprise to some of you but i've never
actually done it
i think there's a few times when i was
in
some financial problems and i asked
allah to help me with that financial
issue but i don't ask allah for money
directly
but one one do i used to make probably
about six years ago when i first started
the the dawah
was allah mentioned
which is that may allah
spread my tower
that was one i used to make
and continue to make actually you know
and so it for me it was a matter of
popularity but not
necessarily in and of itself because to
be honest with you in and of itself it
doesn't really provide much
nourishment
uh it doesn't give you anything it
doesn't improve once well it doesn't
improve one's quality of life i don't
think it does at all to be honest
um
there's a famous a famous discussion
with russell brand and jeremy paxman
yeah where jeremy paxman asks russell
brand this very question
and then russell brand he comes he turns
around he says like he gives a very nice
analogy he says
like fame
is like a meal which
uh when one eats it it kind of is
bland or it's not nourishing or it
doesn't it's not satiating
and so on and so forth and so from that
perspective you know i think i would
agree with that kind of thing fame in
and of itself
can be can to be honest with you
sometimes in inconvenience
you know
because you don't know who's looking at
you and or and who thinks what of you
and you know sometimes you can be with
your family you can be here or there you
can be and it can sometimes be an
inconvenience
and so in and of itself it's i don't
think it's um that valuable to me that
hasn't really increased my quality of
life
like that it has opened up things in
terms of opportunity you know
i'm not i'm not speaking as as a very
famous person we're talking about very
famous people who got the one and only
right here ali dawa next to me want to
take a look at him this is the famous
one this is the champ i'm the famous one
all right next question what was your
most memorable or favorite debate that
you've been in thus far
undoubtedly the david with the break and
there was something about that debate
when we were there like ali remembers um
it was it was a vibe i almost feel like
and i know this might sound uh
sacrilegious but i almost feel like the
angels were there with me on that day i
do feel like there was something going
on in that day that something happened
people don't realize that actually with
david wood i was introduced to his
material when i was like 15 or 16
years old yeah i was i remember watching
it and sometimes i watch a video him and
his friend i'm not going to mention his
name because he's not that well known i
don't want to give him any um popularity
here
but i i watched it when i was in year 10
which is
like when i was 15 or 14 15
and i remember watching those videos and
getting so angry literally physically
angry
and
i vouched
that one day i will be responding to him
from that time and i actually sent him
an email probably when i was in my early
20s he didn't even respond to it maybe
in my teens or early 20s or something
like that asking to debate him so that
day was a culmination of emotions and
anger that i had from my teenage years
you know and so for that i think from
that angle it was very sincere because i
actually wanted to prove him wrong to
show that why he was wrong and all these
kinds of things and from that
perspective i think allah put the
barakah in it he put like the blessings
in it he put he sent down maybe the
angels
but it was definitely something which
was uh is haunting him until this day
you can see
he's making videos about me until now i
mean i think
just two days ago he made a video about
me i mean this is a real desperation and
so
alhamdulillah i mean i think i was very
young at that time 25 or something years
old you know when i've done that debate
but it was just an uphill trajectory
after that and there's something about a
debate with that many people
you know
and there's something about the new york
audience as well
and philadelphia people coming from
philadelphia and people coming from
nearby areas new jersey and so on
really was on it was it made the night
it was a good vibe and so
there's nothing there's nothing i think
that has
thus far compared with that
at all by far yeah
all right next question is
the thing is the grizzly bear i did look
at how to defeat grizzly bear in a fight
a grizzly bear is very difficult there
are three kinds of bear i think there's
one of them where you can fight and beat
i i can't remember which one it is is it
the blue bear or there are three of them
the black man right i think i could i
don't know but i think i could do
something with the black bear whatever
that that bear that's almost my size i
think it has been beat and defeated by
humans in the past and i wouldn't put
myself to be able to give it give that
better decisive blow but if it was a
grizzly bear what i would do
is i would lay on the floor like a log
put cover my essential areas that like
just as it says on the videos
and uh if you know if you're in america
you know you can't really have any
chance with a grizzly bear you have no
chance with the grizzly bear the grizzly
bear is the one that's undefeated
undisputed you know is is
so you have to put yourself on the floor
and cover your vital areas like this and
put your head down and pretend it
pretend play dead basically bye for also
is it the blackberry you said or the
remember it's called blackberry
yeah that one you could fight i think
but i would only do that as a last
resort and if i had
a head
that's funny as as we go on with these
questions you're going to break a few
more hearts with every question that
goes by so i hope you're ready for that
next question
or biryani
which one mundi or biryani it's
oh are you talking about the arabic one
yeah the the emirati
uh okay that's a good one
to be honest as a whole i prefer asian
food it's my favorite food like asian
cuisine biryani is not my favorite type
of thing
biryani is not my favorite type of
indian food but i would go for biryani
yes okay next one is pepsi
pepsi max the one with cherry is good
because it's good tasting and it's zero
calories
all right who's the better cook your
wife or your mom
no doubt about it undisputed undefeated
all right top three places you visited
huh
three places
is number one okay medina is number two
and after that is my country egypt and
uh i would say my city alexandria
alhamdulillah all right do you have and
i hope
you have any
but i'm not gonna tell them because this
is something you're gonna have to pay me
money for
you know because i don't got money but i
asked the people for it
i laid
are there any debates that you kind of
regret doing now
no not at all
okay okay last question
are there any projects that you're
creating that you're very
excited obviously i just i recorded the
thing with hersey uh
ayan mcgann her real name and that's
going to come out on the 1st of march so
i think that's going to be quite
exciting because the way i
i mean i don't know i mean the guys were
here to see it but the way i kind of
laid the smack down
on that on that woman
was i think something which uh people
would like to see
alhamdulillah all right
question from you guys
you have anything romney romney
it was one of the most well received
things i probably think it was the most
well received things i've done wow
especially with non-muslims i think the
amount of um with him i mean as you saw
in that particular thing
it was well received with him and i've
built a relationship with him i hope uh
because the thing is with with peterson
i think he appreciates
disagreeableness i mean he says it
himself people that you know make it in
life are those who are
and people that are yes men around him i
don't think he respects that too much so
the fact that i wasn't afraid
in my public discourses to show my
disagreement with him but at the same
time try and show him respect
and not be antagonistic to him or
provocative to him or disrespectful to
his
placement that was a very very hard
thing to do because it's easier to kind
of let your punches go
if you like because you're doing one
thing you don't have to
moderate yourself you don't have to
mitigate your own responses but with
peterson it was difficult because
i had to make sure that i played the
fight i held the stick by the middle and
so i felt like in many ways the fact
that
i was restraining myself from from being
overly brush or all of the other kind of
i would say vices that i have typically
in my personality structure
i was trying to restrain them i think
from that angle
it was good because it allowed me to
work on my weaknesses
more than accentuate my strengths and
anything that allows you to work on your
weaknesses
rather than accentuate your strengths i
think is a golden opportunity and one
that will build your character
so from that angle i think it
it was good for me and hopefully it was
good for him as well and it's been
viewed by almost two million people now
for the time is pretty good and it's one
of the most i think if not the most
commented
on video on his channel than his entire
channel so
there's a lot of engagement i think that
was positive
and the aim of the game really is to get
is to make the environment more
tolerable one for the muslim community
in the west and to build bridges of
communication and understanding
and i think that those objectives were
met
yeah
how is he off the camera compared to on
the camera is there any difference
i think he's you know i think he's
pretty authentic guy to be honest with
you i think i do actually think he's an
authentic guy
uh you know i i don't know i haven't
really spoken to him too much off the
camera to to be able to make a informed
judgment about him especially from our
paradigm we have to kind of like be with
the person a lot travel with them do
business with them that kind of thing
before we can actually make a judgment
on the character but we can give him the
benefit of the doubt and i think that
really islam is starting to make sense
for him i hope it's going to start
making more sense for him as the time
goes on because it's everything that he
wants from an ideology or from an idea
or from a way of life
it's everything that he's been speaking
about all the diagnoses that he's had of
gender relations in the west
is
a lot of it i'm to say all of it but
much of it is in line with the islamic
discourse
so
i think that he can and obviously his
anti-nihilus discourses and
and so on and so forth a lot of it is
commensurate with islam so i hope i hope
that he looks into that properly and and
he gives it a chance
and i think that he's courageous enough
i do believe he's courageous enough if
he does believe in islam
to announce that and to make that public
because to be honest with you like
you know for him to have me on his
podcast knowing what kind of a
personality i am
uh and he did know what kind of things i
did in the past and whatever i think is
a show of bravery i think it's a show of
courage
and i think it will be equally a show of
courage if not more so
if he was to convert to islam it would
probably be one of the biggest
conversions
uh of the 21st century and so if we can
in any way be a facility of that or
facilitate that then that would be
amazing
yeah 100 i think a big reason why a lot
of like the the muslim audience uh that
he has likes him so much is because of
the agreement between what he you know
preaches a lot and they are islamic
values
so allah you know allah grant um you
know the muslims many more conversations
with them and guidance
so with that being said what are your
goals in terms of dawah for the next
five years
well i'm what i want to do is i want to
complete
my phd i want to um also
um
that's until so i've got
i i divide my goals into different types
in life and also endower so i divide
them from my own perspective
individual goals and then family goals
and community goals
and i would say all three are
inextricably linked to one another and
within my kind of own development i have
the tripartite classification mind body
in the spirit so what you're describing
here goes into the mind if you like
and goes into the community aspect of my
objective so there's two types of
objectives we're talking about
and as i say that they're inextricably
linked so obviously my dowel goals and
my kind of development or personal
development goals
are inextricably linked so one of the
things i want to do is i want to
complete my academic work
on the contingency argument
for god's existence for god's existence
i've already produced a few booklets on
that i want to produce more work on that
because as bruce lee said you know a man
that he
he practices a thousand kicks is not as
feared as a man he wouldn't fear him as
much as a man
who practices one kick ten thousand
times because if you an argument a good
argument is like a
sharp knife
if you have all you need is a few good
arguments
to
that you are really really good at
in order to to really create damage
and to change a social uh understanding
and i'm a believer of that
and you see this in martial arts you see
people having two or three moves
you know and they they go through an
entire career
um
you know with with those moves
you know obviously you have to set them
up you have to all those things but
really you can be a specialist on a move
and that can produce your entire career
so i believe in the same thing when it
comes to dawah
two or three arguments two or three
areas of specialism really focus on them
so the contingency argument being one of
them
and
a few other things which i maybe i'm not
going to disclose straight away because
i don't want people to be working with
me in tandem trying to catch up with me
on those
issues i'm a big believer of uh you know
working silent work in silence and let
you know your actions do
yeah the talking
but after those kind of five years
that's the academic side
as well as like islamic sciences which
i'm continuing to study i believe in a
five to one ratio meaning that what for
every five say hours that i do one hour
i do of dawa
i have to have five at least five times
the amount of
uh input which means like people
teaching me me going through work i
believe in that kind of ratio because
otherwise what advantage do i have over
delay people
you know what really do i have to offer
so i believe in the the five to one
ratio and that means to say that the
islamic sciences is something i also
wish wish to strengthen for the next
five years
uh as as a general what was referred to
as
me i want to really develop all of my
phonon or the islamic sciences we should
really develop each one of them properly
so that when i'm you know
35 years old i can i could be really
solid from that from that angle as well
and also i want to develop my so that's
it in terms of my own personal event in
terms of the dawah
uh
i'm thinking of we're thinking
collectively really to obviously
continue the work that we're doing in
the sapiens institute which is very
important
uh if you don't know already we've got
an institute called the sapiens
institute where in which
we do like work
um we've got like a syllabus now which
we're hoping to develop into a
three-year syllabus almost almost degree
style
we've we've already gone through about
eight months or something called the
london londoner which has been made into
a poem
um so that we want to develop people bro
it's because doing debates and these
kind of things are important but
developing people is more important
and i came to this conclusion more
acutely i think when i had the pulmonary
embolism i had a pulmonary embolism like
blood clots in the lungs
and you know the doctors were telling me
that you have a chance of mortality and
they're being very open about that and
honest
and at that point i thought well i need
to be able to leave something behind
more than just debates and
booklets here and there and you know
some stuff on the internet
in other words i need to leave people
behind that
are developed themselves and that they
can carry on the torch
so a lot of what we're doing is we're
doing like a personal development with
very small groups we're spending a lot
of our time doing that and we want to
continue doing that such that in two
three years time we have people
who have their own areas of specialism
and who can contribute to the dao and
finally i want to get into like more the
the industry the video industry
like produce productions and movies and
stuff like that short movies and we are
we are having discussions and playing
around with this idea i think it
requires a lot more creative input we're
trying to create you know uh more and
more people and obviously i think the
first uh
thing that we're going to have is the
marriage documentary so we'll see what
that's going to do as well because
that's going to be the first of many i
have to say that if i don't yeah
that many other stuff as well many other
things
you know this is something that i think
really it does a lot of community the
idea of producing leaders because we
already have a lot of people that learn
a watered-down version of the deen
unfortunately so to now produce people
that actually understand the deen
and how it ought to be understood in the
sense that it is to be taught it is to
be understood as the way of life not
just a way of life and you know to
produce those leaders can produce more
leaders
i think really really essential
uh that to flourish
the last question i had before i passed
it on to one of the brothers my question
um is in regards to not so much your
specific academic career and the phd
you're pursuing but more generally what
do you think the benefit is in pursuing
the these these credentials do you think
that the knowledge is what's essential
do you think having the credentials is
really important to establish that kind
of authority
i think a bit of both you know honestly
like you know when i first got in
contact with jordan peterson i did so
with the university of oxford email i
think that made a difference you know
like if i were to get in contact with
him with a gmail i think it would make
it like and the fact that he knew that i
was prudentialed in all those aspects
it does make a difference it puts you in
a position of leverage against people
especially like non-muslim people that
are attacking islam there's undoubtedly
that but also there is the knowledge
aspect as well like you know i mean so
when
um
when i'm learning or especially islamic
knowledge
i feel like if you have deadlines in
place if you have deadlines in place and
you have to do like essays or exams and
stuff you you will invariably do more
work
than otherwise okay if you have if you
are a casual reader and you're not
really self motivated then putting
yourself and rolling yourself into
courses and structures is one of the
best ways
to enthuse yourself and to maintain a
level of consistency you know maintain
consistency over a span of time
and so from that angle i think if if you
if you choose a good course that is
actually got a good output
potential then
being enrolled in courses i don't think
it was it's not it's not it's never a
waste of money to invest in education i
don't believe in that i believe that if
you have money investing in education
that's the best thing you can invest in
there's nothing better that you can
invest in than education as sherpa
himself he said that he put half of his
wealth into the study of the arabic
language half of his worth now we don't
imagine that how much money he must have
had and he put into it and he said if i
had if i if i would have i would have
put the entire son into the arabic
language because he saw the value of
knowledge
and so
two things it does give you leverage in
an environment
where the pen has become the substitute
for the sword and number two it does
allow you to be able to
be more productive in such an
environment and also
um you know
and also meet deadlines and
and leverage your opponents
so
to write off that last question bro
there's a lot of people
who would look at you as like an
intellectual academic
type person yeah
so
how would someone who's not an
intellectual who's not an academic
um
i guess acquire this knowledge besides
the consistency i expect
look we go back to the the first stage
what you do
should always be in line with the
objective you choose for yourself so for
me what i'm doing is i'm a polemic
i'm they they you know they call it also
an apologist someone who justifies uh a
controversial that's what the word
apologists mean someone who justifies a
controversial idea in this case islam
being the controversial idea
those things require what i've just
mentioned
and there's almost no substitute for
them if you want to do them at the
highest level i think that's what they
require
but if that's not what you want to be
and you want to be something else then
you have to think about all right so
what the first question that you have to
ask yourself is what is it that you
actually want to contribute and not only
what is it that you want to contribute
what is it that is most what what is it
that you can most effectively contribute
and then as nietzsche said if you have a
wise in almost any house possible you
know when you have that y and you
clearly define it then you work
backwards from it like for me if i want
to show you if i can show you something
here
i have
i carry this kind of like bag yeah look
this is a bag i carry everyone you see
it
yeah i have this bag so anyway i can
have these little i prefer
i still like like writing things in it
so can you see this little diary notepad
i got this from thing called paperchase
what i do in my personal life i've been
doing it since the age of 17 and now i'm
30 so i've been doing this for 13 years
and i like it which is basically
look bro like
okay so i've got categories i'm not sure
if you can see what i'm doing there
can you see it
now you can see there's pralines in that
yeah yeah so what i've got is i've got
rows and columns
and i i i think to myself on a weekly
basis what other thing i got 160 hours
in a week yeah
so i got 168 hours in a week and i think
to myself in a weekly basis what do i
need to do
so i've got columns i'm going to read
all of them to you but there's a lot of
columns yeah but i think that they're
the most important things that not just
for me because that's a very selfish way
of thinking but for me and my family
which i feel like
i need to be outputting or inputting
okay whether it's going to the gym
whether it's doing some studies with my
kids or taking them swimming or whatever
i do with the kids or or myself or you
know what studies i invest in i track it
down and i literally see my productivity
levels on a week to week basis i've been
doing this for 13 years so i see now
what works what doesn't work in exam
periods whatever it is i've been seeing
how i can manage my emotions manage my
my um
my productivity levels you know you
start getting to know yourself more when
you start writing things down that's
something i've seen but if you leave
yourself to just do whatever you need to
do
and you know you've got a very loose the
looser your program
the looser your results
you know that's the reality of the
situation if you leave yourself or you
don't put things down you don't write
things down you don't bar chart things i
used to put things in bar charts and and
then and you know these kind of things
where you see it like this is your
productivity level
i the more you write the more you know
about yourself yeah the more you can get
things right
so in five years you'll be very shocked
and surprised the extent to which you
can completely transform your skill set
in any given field in three to five
years
you can literally go from novice to pro
in five years in almost any given skill
set
but you need to be able to work
backwards i've been doing that for the
last third i'd say 13 to 15 years so i
feel like you know if
if one invests their time in in really
detailing in their lives what they want
to do
then that's the first thing so you need
to ask yourself what do you actually
want to achieve
and you go ask yourself go back to the
tripartite classification you know the
mind the body and the spirit okay so
what do you want to achieve from the
mind perspective the spirit perspective
and the body perspective what do you
want to chew for yourself what do you
want to chew for your family members
what do you want to achieve from your
community or for your community once
you've understood all of that then you
can work
in
in line with that that's why i think it
has to be done but also i would add one
more thing to this the quran says
something really powerful
it
says
everyone should work on their form
okay like everyone has something
that they are have been given
another verse
do not wish what allah has given some of
you that he hasn't given others
and in fact this is a gender discussion
for men is a portion of what they have
earned and for women is a portion of
what they have earned
and ask
but the point is is that you need to see
not just what you're good at
sorry not just what you want to do but
what you're actually good at as well
like for example all of you guys sorry
i'm i'm moving my head all of you guys
can speak the english language now you
can speak the english language with not
just any accent but you can speak the
english language with an american accent
now you might think that's a trivial
thing but let me tell you something
right having the american accent
english-speaking language puts you in
the 5th 95th percentile in the world's
population of being able to speak
english not just english language but
you can speak it in a proof in a accent
that many people would love to have now
that you might think that's something
negligible or sorry trivial but it's not
actually trivial because it allows you
to do things which maybe 95 of other
people would not be able to do for
example having this channel so you need
to be able to make a proper critical
self-assessment
on your actual strengths and you need to
start thinking about things which you
maybe take for granted
you know and once you understand what
your strengths are then it's better and
easier to build on them
you know and i feel like
if we build on our strengths and work on
our weaknesses what really do accentuate
our strengths that can put us on a next
level and that can
that puts us in a better position to be
able to leave like a proper fingerprint
uh
you know on world's history but that's
that's basically how i put it you need
to think about in some therefore you
need to think about what you want to
contribute to the world
and then you need to work backwards and
you need to work backwards on a
day-to-day basis
hold yourselves to account before you
are held to account
this is a very powerful thing
it's if you hold yourself to account by
how much you spend how much you eat you
know i've started doing this thing on
myfitnesspal i'm not sure if you guys
know you i'm sure you guys know this uh
this uh this app
i was shocked to know how many calories
i consume on a daily basis about four
thousand you know so i realized okay if
i yeah and it's you know it's funny
enough it told me if you want to lose
weight you can you could eat 3 500
calories one half a kilo a week which is
like what i don't know like a pound or
something a week more than a pound
so if i anyway just know what you what's
coming into your body what's coming into
your soul what's coming what you are
consuming and what you are outputting
and hold yourself to account on that
basis
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto because there's this
thing called inflation which means every
year that passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
that's awesome man it reminds me a lot
of uh you know who jacob willing is
oh yeah i think so yeah
yeah he's got he's got a contest yeah
yeah so he had said something along the
lines of like discipline equals freedom
and what you just said it just kind of
highlighted that where you're writing
everything down and you're holding
yourself accountable
and seeing the progress that's being
made therefore allowing you to reverse
engineer everything and get the results
that you're looking for yeah it's like
the old spot says you know it says that
you've got two pains either the pain of
discipline or the pain of regret
and most people unfortunately
they they opt for the second unknowingly
unwittingly or otherwise
you know i'm preferring unpreferably and
what i'm saying is that this is
something that we can actually make a
choice for today and and i feel like if
what if you don't have a solid
a solid plan if you don't if you don't
uh plan to if you fail to plan
plan to fail basically
if you fail to plan plan to fail
you will be in a position where you will
not you will not achieve what you want
to achieve you will have a crisis maybe
in your mid 30s or 40s
you you you will not feel as if you've
done what you could do
the the islam
make gives such
you know it has such an emphasis on time
in the
that by time that surely
you know human being is in a state of
loss
except for those who do good works and
you know um
believe and do good works whatever
happens
he said
that we are all it's very interesting
what he said he said that we are all
days
and every day we lose a part of
ourselves
yeah we are basically all days and every
day we lose a part of ourselves we're
like snow walking snowmen we're melting
away we're melting away so we only have
a very limited time to get done what we
need to get done
and so if once one had that kind of like
quite frankly the
the imp the that impetus
that kind of um urgency narrative i feel
like
that that's the beginning of success
that is the very beginning of success
so with that being said man
what does the day look like for you
what does a day look like for me
yeah
i mean you got a little notebook you're
writing everything down
yeah so it depends on the day but uh
largely speaking there are things that i
do on a day-to-day basis which are the
same
uh
some of them i can't mention now i'm
only joking so so basically the things
that i do that i try and and do
i try and because i have the pulmonary
embolism okay i couldn't do martial arts
and still basically cannot do any heavy
martial arts for some time right so
that's one thing that i'm gonna
come and shut allah back into
you know i think uh next week or the
week after because i'm on blood thinners
so i need to get off those blood
thinners to get but basically i have to
do a lot of martial arts but the point
is is
um
on a day on a day-to-day basis these are
the things that i have to do number one
i have to do quran i have to do ask
myself so before i think at my height i
had a daily plan of doing one hour and a
half of quran either
which is basically going on and
basically this is the most important
thing if you don't have quran in your
day-to-day i think life then quite
frankly you're not following the sunnah
you cannot really be a diet because
what are you going to give to people you
know the prophet saws
the best of you are those who learn the
quran
the quran itself
we have made the quran easy for
remembrance so who's going to come and
remember it allah has made it easy you
know it's one of one of the the things
which allah has actually made so easy
for the people is quran to memorize the
quran to understand it to
even just
or something like that basically doing
it with tajweed and he says that some
people that don't do quran with tajweed
is a sinner
one of the greatest scholars
and the prophet muhammed said on this
matter he says
that the one who is proficient with the
quran is with the high and lofty angels
and the one who finds it difficult to
listen to this one the one who finds it
difficult
and he is
to pronounce the words and so on he gets
two rewards that person gets two rewards
and the prophet muhammed
that's it he says
he says i don't say alif
the alif is a half one letter and lam is
a half one letter and meme is a half one
letter and for each letter
is ten rewards now we know there's
seventy seven thousand words in the
quran
and of them probably the average amount
of
letters is five to seven let's say seven
so seventy seven thousand times seven is
a times seven let's just say seven times
seven which is uh you know
uh forty nines that's a what forty nine
49
494 million 900 000 something like that
rewards like 5 million rewards from the
quran one time
that i i seldomly can see or think of a
thing that you can do on your day-to-day
basis
which can be more rewardable which can
be more psychologically nourishing which
can be more healing because the quran is
shift
then read in the quran the days that i
don't read the quran i feel down i feel
like
as if something bad has happened to me
something's
sad i feel like i've wasted my time
sometimes i read other books
and those other books i feel sometimes
sad because i'm thinking why am i
reading this kalama bashar the human
being's words
then rather than the killing of the
human beings i've been to four
universities in my life
you know and as i sometimes some people
think well you've learned so much from
the university
sometimes because i memorize about 95 of
the quran in my car people don't know
this in my car driving to places because
i couldn't do everything at one time
so i have sometimes learned more driving
to universities than inside the
university itself because when i'm
driving to the university i'm reading
the quran but when i'm going and i'm
listening to a white man speak about
liberalism whatever it is and whatever
he has to say is nothing better than
what i have read when i was coming on
the way
so as i say read in the quran if you
don't put the quran as the centerpiece
of your life
then there's no time yes there's no
difference between you
and everybody else that is basically
in society you have nothing to offer
it's it is the illumination it is the
uh centerpiece of the islamic faith
so quran the second thing
is i've mentioned which is you can you
can listen to it now you don't even i've
got it on my channel as well the morning
and evening supplications and i've
translated it so if this is something
which the prophet saws telling me to do
all the time and some of those
supplications are worth so much reward
that it's vegas belief that people
actually forego this on a day-to-day
basis it begs belief really to be honest
with you
so that's the second thing the third
thing is i try to do lifting weights
about three to four times a week let's
see three times a week a three day split
you know i try to do that obviously i've
got my i'm that i do so on a certain
selected days
i study islam
and i study i've got about four or five
very close teachers which i study with
them you know i study uh bukhari on
sundays and to be honest with you bihari
we're going through
which will take about seven years to
complete we've done about 10 of it you
know we go through other books we've got
other teachers that takes up a lot of my
time
you know i we go through
and that takes up a lot of my time you
know going through other uh other things
this is like i feel a great sense of of
achievement and happiness contentment
when i'm going through these particular
islamic fields because it is the
the it is the holy um
knowledge it's not just any knowledge
i've studied a lot of other things and
to be honest with you it's like nonsense
sorry to say most of it i study and i am
not interested in it really what i'm
interested in is the quran really what
i'm interested is what the prophet
sallam said if i just go through three
hadiths i've never heard before it makes
my day because something is imagine
you're you're you're you're being
communicated with by the prophet
muhammad
the messenger of allah and there's new
information that he hasn't that you
haven't heard him say that you hear him
say going through the hadith
very important and so every day i
actually i do with my kids i do about 20
to 30 minutes of arabic as well arabic
lesson and you know they get they're
starting to because i also try and give
back to their my kids and my family and
stuff like that and i've also got like
uh dude lessons with other people in my
family some from time to time but i'm
trying to focus on the children a little
bit more
and take them swimming once a week do
you know they're starting to do bjj now
they've been doing it for a long time
play fight rough and what's it called
rough and tumble play whatever i do a
lot of that with them you know so
there's a family time i do a lot of
family time stuff you know
uh obviously we've got we're filming we
come and we've got filming about three
times a week i've got a teaching which
we do about two to three times a week so
that's uh that's basically it i can try
and break it down and when i was doing
martial arts i would do that i plan to
do that four times maybe five times a
week depending on the week
so that's basically uh uh really yeah
and i try and break it down and change
up but then obviously the schedule
starts building up
and i do i need to do but the staple
things i do on a day-to-day basis which
wherever i may be in the world i will do
is the quran
it is the ascar it is the um
it is
or the accountability self
accountability is something something to
do with the body so some exercise
something like that you know and so on
it's probable i i definitely have more
questions but i want to open the floor
up to the other two brothers here just
in case they have anything else they
want to add
there's one thing on my mind right now
what are your advice to fathers
well you know to be honest with you
you know it's easy for a man to be
distracted from his children i think
sometimes we just have these
tendencies it's difficult so what i do
is someone who has a proclivity towards
to to distraction
is up i put things
uh i systemati systematize things i
schedule things i try and make things
into a routine
so my my thing is
with your children first of all you can
spend years and years and years
of having children and then not not
giving them like their their rights so
the way out of that is to system to have
a routine with the children
a daily routine a weekly routine my
routine are the children as i mentioned
i've got the arabic lessons i do with
them i've got like the kind of rough and
tumble play i take them swimming once a
week you know
i take them out sometimes i take them
out but that's less often
you've got to do things like that you
got to put that in because if you don't
then you won't have that influence on
your child they will not be attached to
you
you will and by the way it's really it's
very important to know that you spending
time with your kids is not a favor to
them it's a favor to yourself because in
fact what it does
is it activates endorphins in your body
and it does things for you
from a mental health perspective which
elevates your state so if you try and
eliminate that part of your life you are
only doing that to your own discredit
and disfavor
so my point is sometimes we can be
selfish as fathers but if you are of
that type you have to systematic
systematize things you have to schedule
things you have to make things routine
and uh and that is in your favor because
at the end of the day it's one of the
greatest
um adornments of the dunya
as the quran states you know
that children and wealth are the
adornment of this life
if you can't even make use of that
then it's the problem is with you
uh you know you're only harming yourself
my last question is
what are some things that you see men
like today
i feel like well in the muslim community
and in the west we have to be more
specific
in the west where what country and what
and what
in the west
right so i i think that you know
obviously there are issues to do with
westernization there's issues to do with
the ideological
subversion that's happened and take over
and uh
you know that kind of thing especially
in america unfortunately i've been to
canada as you know many times i've i
think i've seen you around me in person
haven't i yeah
yes that's right so i've been to canada
many times i've been to america many
times
and i i differentiate there's parts of
america like philadelphia like new york
where people especially the black
community because a lot of them already
used to being against the dominant
community you know being mavericks in
that sense in regards to civil rights
and so on that don't really have a
problem with the rules of islam but
unfortunately especially within you know
subcontinental and arab
uh muslims you know
a lot of them there's a tendency to try
and bow the knee to the dominant culture
and i think that is one of the biggest
problems as a result of it we're seeing
more egalitarian discourse we're seeing
more divorce
statistically american muslims are
almost on par in divorce rates with the
dominant population and the reason why
that is is because they are unable to
have stable families because they no
longer believe in hierarchies they don't
but no longer believe that i managed to
be the man of the house and they should
have the final say on a managerial
capacity as a result of that what we're
seeing is the disintegration of family
stabilizing of such families and we're
seeing divorce and and we are just
becoming part of the fabric you know it
actually angers me to see that we are
letting this kind of narrative
take place and because what is i feel
like especially in western discourses
you have like the right wing
are very much anti-muslim in sentiment
many of them not all of them but many of
them are anti-muslim and sentiment but
the the left-wing can be very much
anti-islam
but the way in which they will try and
influence muslims is through micro
liberalism micro feminism
you know um
you know this kind of an approach where
it's yeah
it's a so-called tolerant approach which
is actually a very subversive approach
but unfortunately the naive amongst us
and the weakest amongst us will fall
prey to this kind of thing men will not
stand their ground and you'll have
entire communities of people
bowing the knee to the dominant culture
in the name of maslaha in the name of
like you know a you know a master of
talaq master of um
which is called
which they've taken to a completely
like unusual level
and they've made the religion into
something almost completely distinct
a diluted religion a different religion
and so i think this is one of the
biggest problems because they have
allowed the western narratives
enlightenment narratives to define
gender roles especially
but not not limited to the feminist
second wave feministic discourse men
have now they're rented rendered
impotent in the family environment to be
able to put their foot down and they
can't even do they can't even do the
basics and telling their daughters you
know this is wrong to wear this or this
is don't flirt with this guy you don't
have these extra marital
relationships so what we're seeing is
the emasculation emasculation of men
wholesale in the muslim community
this is less so the case i think in
britain but because british muslims are
working class but a lot of a lot of a
lot this is a correlation correlative
thing it's not necessarily causative but
many of the communities which muslim
communities in the west which opt to
this kind of
narrative
are middle class muslims
and the reason why a middle class
meaning you know
i think you guys call it something else
upper class something in america but
middle class
are the higher echelons people of higher
socioeconomic order because it's in
their interest to stay with the
egalitarian line not the complementary
and traditionalist line because if they
go against the egalitarian line it will
have severe consequences in their work
environment and they will lose money so
a lot of people are just because they
know if they speak in a manner which
goes against the man or the
establishment or the dominant ideology
that they may be demoted or otherwise
fired or otherwise not being given the
opportunities that others have
they tend towards a version of
i want to call it that diluted
amalgam synthetic religion really that's
what it is which is a new religion that
they've concocted which is islamo
liberalism of the american uh
uh or a kind and so because of that i
think men have become
uh they accept things which in in
history of islamic uh civilization would
never be acceptable at all and so the
only way unfortunately is that this can
really be there's two ways either
theoretically the people will walk
through dawah
except
as either call back to islam and to come
back to the kitab and the sunnah all
that it has to be experiential because
when all when all else fails
life has the teaches the best lessons
this could go on for for a lot longer
but uh unfortunately i think we're out
of time here
uh so
with that being said
may allah bless
all the work that you do
i mean it was a pleasure having you on i
can say that you know very firmly about
myself and probably about the other two
brothers as well as
your work and bless you mostly
thanks so much for having me and
obviously uh
uh you know
promising the religion and helping each
other out and if there's anything
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel inshallah
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]